les sens déterminent notre expérience du
monde la façon dont une pomme a le goût de la façon dont les
peaux de Simon ressentent la façon dont nous voyons le ciel
ce recensement façonne notre réalité
imaginez maintenant que vos sens sont croisés alors
quand vous entendez une voiture passer, vous pouvez
aussi goûter au caramel ou quand  vous voyez
quelque chose de vert vous entendez un accord G sonne
cool a l'air cool et a un goût cool quatre
virgule quatre pour cent de la population a
cette ligne droite et si vous avez ce trait,
vous pouvez penser que tout ce que je dis est
évident si vous ne le faites pas, vous ne me croirez peut-
être pas à  du moins jusqu'en 1987 où les
scientifiques prouvent le phénomène avec des
IRM c'est réel certaines personnes voient le
mot Monda est lu mais ne vous inquiétez pas c'est
toujours une journée de merde pour tout le monde si vous
voulez savoir si vous l'avez combien de
deux pouvez-vous voir  il y en a six si
vous ressemblez à quelque chose comme ça ou vous pouvez
séparer les outils des cinq en
ayant une idée d'une couleur pour chaque forme que
vous avez synesthésie c'est un oui ne vous
inquiétez pas il n'y a rien de mal avec vous
c'est un  menace en ayant des taches de rousseur et si
vous n'avez pas réagi au test, vous pourriez
toujours être synesthésique
car il existe de nombreuses
variations différentes personnalité aux nombres
nombres aux couleurs couleurs au son douleur
au son saveurs à la couleur ou orgasme aux
saveurs il y a au moins soixante-dix type  de
synesthésie dans un van gock Duke Ellington
Kanye West Marilyn Monroe et c'est peut-
être fou ce que je vais dire même
Pharrell Williams alors qu'ils ont tous
ça en commun la
synesthésie que Kanye décrit utilise comme une
peinture sonore et Pharrell raconte le
refrain de happy is  un petit
arc-en-ciel rose et si vous vous demandez pourquoi
beaucoup d'artistes ont ce trait, c'est
parce que vous pouvez avoir une perception plus complète
de l'art reproduit et un
sens différent de l'harmonie un bon
exemple est le peintre d'origine russe
Basilica
skee travaillant dans  le début des années 1900 kadinsky
était considéré comme une esthétique
pour Kandinsky certains sons déclenchés par la couleur
sont des notes de musique et vice-versa
donc pour lui un concert serait  ressembler à un long
tourbillon de couleurs avec différents points,
tirets et traits qui indiquent les nuances
de la musique lorsqu'il était enfant, il pouvait entendre un
sifflement lors du mélange des couleurs dans la
boîte de peinture plus tard, il a dit que le son
d'un violoncelle présentait le plus profond de
tous les blues  de nombreux artistes contemporains sont
formés aujourd'hui très saint l'un d'eux
son expérience synesthésique inspire sa
vie des peintures puis-je vraiment vivre la
synesthésie
eh bien oui la technologie aide les gens à se
rapprocher de l'expérience synthétique la
première chose à laquelle vous penserez naturellement
est un appareil par exemple le  port cérébral
de nous plaçons un edie de vision électronique
qui traduit les informations vidéo en direct
en modèles de stimulation électrique doux
qui sont ressentis comme des vibrations ou des
picotements et la surface de la langue de l'utilisateur,
c'est idéal pour les aveugles,
ils peuvent sentir leur environnement à travers
leur langue et il y a  aussi Zachary
Howard un ingénieur en aérospatiale qui a fait un
masque qui utilise un microprocesseur de capteur de couleur
un  nd huiles essentielles pour que vous
puissiez goûter des sons mais ne me fait pas vraiment l'
expérience de la synesthésie je veux dire
est-ce que j'aurai vraiment ces capteurs mélangés
ou sera-ce juste une pure mutation dans
le futur comment vais-je pouvoir confondre
mes sens pour améliorer ma créativité
pourrai-je facilement jouer avec mes sens
ou pouvons-nous aller plus loin que cela, comme
créer un tout nouveau sens et si nous
avions un capteur qui nous permettait de voir l'
infrarouge et les UV se rencontrer près de Harbison Je suis
un artiste cyborg et l'art cyborg est  la
création ou l'art de la création de
vos propres sens et l'art de la
création de vos propres organes sensoriels et
mes clés J'ai un nouvel organe sensoriel qui
est une antenne et un nouveau sens qui
détecte la couleur à travers la conduction osseuse
et va au-delà  le spectre visuel donc
de l'infrarouge à l'ultraviolet, j'ai aussi
une connexion Internet dans ma tête qui
me permet de recevoir des couleurs d'autres
parties du monde ou du satellite
et l'utilisez-vous pour faire de l'art Je me
rapproche de la fa de quelqu'un  ce et puis
j'écoute le son des yeux les lèvres
les cheveux la peau puis je crée le
portrait sonore puis au lieu de
leur envoyer une image du visage de quelqu'un
j'envoie le son du visage de quelqu'un Wow
donc vous avez fondamentalement un nouveau sens  puis-je
être un cyborg nous sur nos panneaux latéraux psychologiques
il y a une union entre nous et la
technologie psychologique très forte et
cette union commence à devenir
biologique nous commencerons à voir plus de
gens émerger biologiquement avec la
cybernétique et avec la technologie et
nous commencerons  voir des gens avec de nouveaux
sens et de nouveaux organes très bientôt, il se
produit déjà qu'il deviendra lentement
normal de rencontrer des gens avec de nouveaux
sens et de nouveaux organes sensoriels, mais comme
il ne s'agit pas seulement d'art et de belles
couleurs, d'odeurs incroyables et d'orgasmes colorés,
cela pourrait aussi aider  nous, à plus grande
échelle, les scientifiques parlent de la façon dont
cela aide à améliorer les compétences d'apprentissage lors de la
récupération d'une lésion cérébrale et à prévenir
le déclin mental chez les personnes âgées.
futur, nous pourrions tous nous procurer de
nouveaux sens des sens qui n'existent pas
quels sens voudriez-vous avoir bien
faites le moi savoir dans la section des commentaires oh
et j'ai des dibs sur la vision à 360 degrés
évidemment pour plus d'histoires sur l'art et la
technologie donner  le bouton d'abonnement un
clic et regardez plus de nos vidéos